[موسيقى]
حيث نرى الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم يؤثر على
تحويل الصناعة المزدوجة لدينا
بالتأكيد سيكون لديه الكثير من
الفرص والإمكانيات التي رأيناها
بالفعل خلال الأشهر الأربعة الماضية
مع الكثير من الأنشطة التي تحدث حول
ما يمكن أن يفعله الذكاء الاصطناعي في صناعة السفر و
بالنسبة للصناعات الأخرى
عندما يتعلق الأمر بصناعة الفنادق
على وجه التحديد ، فإننا نرى بالتأكيد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي
يؤثر أو يعزز بطريقة ما
رحلة العميل
حتى نتمكن من البدء أولاً ربما من خلال النظر
في كيفية تحسين المحادثات وأنت
تعرف السائق الذي يمكنه
التفاعل حقًا  مع نموذج الرسوم البيانية ولدينا
نفس الخبرة البشرية
وهنا نرى الكثير من التحسينات في الذكاء الاصطناعي ، والجانب
الآخر هو كيف سيؤثر الذكاء الاصطناعي على
القرارات التي نتخذها
والضيافة لأن الذكاء الاصطناعي قادر على
تحليل كمية هائلة من البيانات
وبالتأكيد  سيساعد تحديد الاتجاهات التي توفر
الأنماط واستخدامها
الصناعة في اتخاذ قرار أفضل
وتنفيذ التوصيات الصحيحة وأن تكون
استباقيًا والطريقة التي نخدم بها عملائنا
كلما تم إصدار تقنية جديدة
للمستخدمين النهائيين ، من المهم جدًا أن تكون على دراية
بالأمان  الخصوصية وعند
التفاعل مع تلك المنصات
واليوم لأن الذكاء الاصطناعي
لا يزال عندما تم وضعه لأول مرة في
نهاية المستهلكين فهو شيء
جديد ولهذا السبب لا نرى حتى الآن أي
جراثيم قانونية أو حكومية
تعرف أنها تحمي النهاية  المستخدمين أو
المؤسسة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالأمان
والخصوصية ، لذلك من
المهم جدًا أن يفهم المستخدم النهائي أين تأتي
القائمة
حتى لا نتمكن من استخدامها كمصدر
لاتخاذ قرارات حاسمة ومع ذلك
فهو مساعد حتى نتمكن من  نشير دائمًا
إلى ذلك والجانب الآخر هو أننا
نحتاج أيضًا إلى أن ندرك أنه لا يمكننا
استخدامه كما قلنا قاعدتنا
للبحث ولكن يمكننا الاعتماد عليها
لإرشادنا بطريقة معينة ،
شكرًا لك